I'm good I'm hanging in there yeah you
guys just finished uh finished up a
little move you've been working on it
yeah yeah we just finished a couple days
ago very exciting yeah and you guys know
what they're talking about from will it
be 2018 when we see infinity war right
that's right
what for you this is I think your
seventh or eighth eighth film that
you'll be captain American with amazing
yeah does that make it easier for you or
is that does not not really affect the
challenge ah the challenge I mean it
certainly becomes you know is you're
very familiar with the role you're
familiar with the people you're working
with so the working experience gets a
bit easier with the changes in corporate
Hollywood you know with Fox and Disney
and such there's a chance to see
potentially someday and the Avengers
versus the x-men I wonder if that's
something that's it's kind of fun to
think about or with a Fantastic Four and
you could play two characters like a
little Parent Trap right I doubt they'd
ever let me do that though yeah well
there's the invaders too and that's to
the members of the Human Torch in can i
or kcb says recently i happen to be
sitting next to Hugh Jackman at this Wow
all right here we go
so Wow I didn't know that what other
awkward thing I could talk about but to
be like am I gonna see seen I don't know
and but he said a couple of things to me
and I'll just I'll just leave it at that
because I feel like otherwise I'm gonna
get into trouble with somebody but no
you know but but yeah you know I asked
him cuz I kept thinking I was like he
said whether or not that was Logan was
supposed to be the last
Wolverine thing or whatever and and it's
you know he'd said to me what he's I
think he publicly said out there which
was like he's been thinking about it and
he you know it's on his mind so I don't
know he maybe
I think Sebastian I think phones off
please please are can you rewind the
last 15 seconds Twitter just broke way
to go awesome well let's keep that going
um so Justice League how about you guys
fight to Justice League maybe we could
do who is that
yeah exactly
[Applause]
we won the last 35 seconds record over
that with Infinity Ward the Guardians
did you guys get to hang out with them
much or not what can we say what what do
people know no we hung out a lot on set
the trailer is out trailer yeah mr.
trailer Thor looks at him and goes who
are you yeah now that was a good Thor
[Music]
yeah he really grumbles those lines out
I'm Chris Hemsworth yeah yeah they're
great I mean that that was the best part
of this movies that you really kind of
it really was for the first time for me
feeling like the first few movies it
almost feels like it's happening to
somebody else you kind of feel like
you're watching it happen but you're not
actually a part of it and this was kind
of the first movie where you actually
felt like you had a seat at the table
and you belonged and it was so nice to
have all these other franchises that
you've watched and admired come to a set
where you're like oh man I I belong here
and and all these great people are part
of a movie that we're all doing together
and and it was just it was just
wonderful because all those franchise I
mean let's be honest Marvel doesn't miss
they haven't missed yet like they
they're they're batting a thousand I
don't know how they do that know that
they don't miss and so to see all of
these actors come together from all
these other franchises that I've seen as
fans you know be exchanging dialog with
me it was just kind of it was
overwhelming and and and really just so
satisfying cuz truly truly truly there's
not one bad apple now there was one day
we were on set we're doing this scene
that's in the trail that where we're all
running into battle and Sebastian's
hares doing this
and it does that it does and you know
all of us are on set and it's just like
40 superheroes and I look to my right
and I see Tom Holland and that might be
the only poem on there are we done on
that movie
are we done all right how we do it thank
you I see Tom Holland and Dave Bautista
scream for that guy not Tom Holland I
see the two of them over in the corner
and Tom is literally the size of Dave's
lake right so I don't know what they're
talking about but Batista jumps up and
does like a kick punch move Superman I'm
teaching him and I was like no you're
about to kill him what are you doing
so I run off I'm like what's going on
and then you see Tom trying to do it
it's like you know and it's just we have
there were so many different moments
like that on set where you see people
just do stuff where you'd step out of it
and you're you're like you know it's
like a you're a voyeur in a way like
you're you know your spectator you'll
see yeah it was a great day with a lot
of great people and it was overwhelming
and really humbling but is there one
thing about maybe your characters not
plot wise more about where they're at
that you can give us a little just kind
of flavor of and you have a beard in the
film listen yeah yeah I had a beard I
got a beard they gave me the beard you
know I think there's a real it's always
tricky because I know there's a lot of
purists who kind of want you know
capsule look a certain way and you know
they hate even the colors in the suits
you know I remember even with Winter
Soldier the suit being that stealth suit
the navy suit which I loved
I brought your eyes out thanks man
made him pop made him go back and watch
that movie they pop verses that first
Avengers soo which you know it was not
one of my faves now but but you know so
it's a try and you know discuss whether
or not we let the look deviate from the
origin you know went through a few
discussions but but it was really nice
that they let that happen and it lends
itself to the arc and to what he's what
he's going through I got to be careful I
don't wanna give too much away it's
tricky but yeah it was nice it was nice
for that film to kind of have not not
just a different look but but uh you
know a different headspace yeah you know
coming off such a huge battle that these
characters are coming off of everybody's
trying to find their footing again you
know everybody's trying to figure out
where they are and how they'll be
accepted and looked upon not only by the
rest of the world but by the other
heroes since we've been separated so
that's kind of a overall idea of you
know where we're coming from and how do
we get out of that and save the world
hey everybody whole bunch of Infinity
Ward or breakdown then telling behind
the scenes stories the spider-man one is
probably my favorite but they also told
a bunch of jokes like Who news that
Chris Evans hated that first Avengers
suit that he wore which we also just saw
him wearing in behind the scenes picks
for Avengers 4 so when he says that they
just finished filming he's talking about
Avengers 4 although most of their
marketing is based on infinity war right
now we still don't know what the title
for Avengers for us but they're still
billing it as the infinity wars as in
plural like two separate parts of a
giant war even though the second film is
really different from the first film but
if you're just finding me for the first
time be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's an Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway going on now - I'll explain at
the end of the video but just real quick
the things that I actually think they
were talking about when they were
talking about the behind-the-scenes
moments like where Drax was trying to
teach spider-man Tom Holland himself how
to do like a big wrestling style
superhero punch where you jump up and
punch someone that scene was probably
from them fighting Thanos here like
where you see Thea nose grab spider-man
and jam him to the ground
he might just wind up grabbing
spider-man midair as he is swinging in
like if
you saw that comic book panel from comic
book Infinity Gauntlet spider-man swings
in trying to hit that O's they probably
did a version of that in the movie but
the other big thing Sebastian Stan
talking to Hugh Jackman about maybe
coming back because of this Disney deal
now like Hugh Jackman if you watch other
interviews he'll say the exact opposite
like no man I played the character too
many times it's been too much but very
clearly Sebastian Stan is trying to
avoid saying that Hugh Jackman told him
that he's thinking about coming back
like he talks around it a little bit
like aw I'm gonna get in trouble with
someone for saying this but he's been
thinking about it so we should go
without saying that even if the fox's
disney deal goes through and they get
the okay to do whatever they want with
all the characters it's still too late
for them to actually include Wolverine
in infinity War part 1 or part 2 so the
way to include an x-men character in
Avengers 4 is in some sort of post
credits tag where they tease the idea of
the characters and then they can
actually put them on screen in whatever
subsequent film because think about the
timeline Avengers 4 premieres next year
meaning the film will be done within
like a month or so of that like they do
CG right up until the last minute but
the Fox Disney deal is gonna take almost
18 months to make it through regulatory
bodies in the government so it's gonna
take longer to approve the deal than it
will for Avengers 4 to come out meaning
that if they're gonna do anything really
big with the x-men characters it'll be
during a phase four film it won't be
during Avengers 4 but don't be surprised
if they tease something at the end of
Avengers 4 or around it like oh you know
maybe there's some Fantastic Four stuff
that's going to be happening down the
road
the real question I think is as if given
Feige is going to address that deal at
Comic Con this summer but like I said
there's a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet replica giveaway all you have
to do to enter just be a subscriber
leave a Marvel related comment on the
video but there was a bunch of new comic
book stuff that just dropped so I'll try
to get through it as fast as possible
click here for brand new Deadpool and
click here for brand new black panther
in the Black Widow movie thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]